الورقه التاليه لاردوغان والتي اشهرنا
اليها قبل قليل هي اليونان الخلافات بين
البلدين حول جزر البحر ايجاد تصاعدت عام
2000 تحديدا مع اكتشاف احتياطات كبيره من
النفط والغاز الشرقي المتوسط واضافه الى
ثرواتها الطبيعيه بتمون اهميه الجزر في
موقعها كان نقطه اتصال مباشر مع عدد من
البحار المفتوحه وسيطراتها على عدد من
المضائق والخللجان التي تجعلها تتحكم في
الوضع الاجمالي للملاحه الحره في المنطقه
الجوهره ثانيه تاخذاني سباق تطوير
الترسانه البحريه والبدايه بتركيا العام
الجاري دخلت غواصه باريس تركيا الخدمه
والاولى ضمن ست غواصات فئه فئه تريس وهي
نسخه من الغواصات الالمانيه الشهيره 24 لا
تصدر الغواصه انبعاثات صوتيه
يضاف الى ظروف الجغرافيا المحيطه بتركيا
من بحار شبه مغلقه ومياه ضاحيه قدرتها على
التخفي فائقه
عاملات الطائرات بمثابه مطارات عائمه
يمكنها الرسول لفترات طويله في اماكن لا
يمكن لطائرات القوات البريه الوصول اليها
وهنا حاملات تي جي جي انادول وهي نسخه
معدله من السفينه اخوان كارلوس الاسبانيه
كان يفترض بناؤها لمقاتلات اف 35 بيئه
التي لم تستلمها انقره فقررت تعديل خطه
التصميم لتتكون حمولتها من المروحيات
والمسيرات اليونان من جانبها تعملوا على
رفع مستوى الردع البحري ده تعاقد مع باريس
على شراء فرقه اف دي اي مجهزازه برضارات
حديثه توفر توفره قدره عاليه المستوى في
مجالات الحرب الالكترونيه المضاده
للطائرات والغوا ويطيح التسليح الجيد
للفرقاطه تنفيذ مهام مرافقه مضاده
للغواصات اليونانيه مارك بي او مارك خمسه
زورق دوريه خاصه امريكا الصنع
استخداماته متعدده وابرزها تنفيذ عمليات
الاعتراض البحري اليونان قويه ايضا